responsive design I know it's fun to
resize your web browser and see which
sites do size gracefully and which size
remain defiantly large with gross
horizontal scroll bars but responsive
design is not just for the web today the
lines between phones and tablets are
disappearing
so it's important to think about how
your UI will scale in our multi-screen
world don't be overwhelmed just like
designing responsive layouts for the web
build your layouts to be reasonably
flexible or within a common device size
then you can set breakpoints providing
alternative layouts for those various
sizes think about it this way small
phone large phone medium tablet pan
large tablet